en otros vídeos hemos hecho rectas de
regresión a mano pero mencionamos que la
mayor parte de las rectas se hacen
usando alguna computadora o calculadora
lo que haremos en este vídeo es ver un
ejemplo de salida de datos de una
computadora y cómo encontrar la ecuación
para la recta de regresión y otra
información que nos proporciona carolina
está interesada en ver si los
estudiantes que consumen más cafeína
tienden a estudiar más ella elige
aleatoriamente a 20 estudiantes de su
escuela y registra su consumo de cafeína
en miligramos y el número de horas que
estudian una gráfica de los datos
muestra una relación lineal esta es una
salida de computadora del análisis de
regresión de mínimos cuadrados de la
información tenemos todos estos datos
cómo podemos entenderlos para poder
encontrar la ecuación de nuestra
regresión lineal primero definamos las
variables digamos que es lo que sea que
queremos definir en este caso las horas
de estudio digamos que x es lo que
nosotros pensamos que es una de las
cosas que explican las horas de estudio
y representa la cantidad de cafeína
en miligramos así que nuestra recta de
regresión va a tener la forma y con
sombrero esto nos dice que es una
regresión lineal y trata de estimar los
valores 10 reales de una x dada va a ser
igual a m por x + b cómo podemos
determinar los valores de m idv usando
esta salida de computadora cuando vemos
la tabla la primera columna dice
predictora luego dice constante y
después dice cafeína lo que nos dice
esto es que cuando tratamos de predecir
el número de horas de estudio o cuando
tratamos de predecir y debemos
básicamente dos entradas
el valor constante de nuestra variable
que en este caso es la cafeína con la
que tratamos de predecir la cantidad de
horas de estudio esta columna nos dice
los coeficientes para cada una el
coeficiente de una constante es la
constante pueden ver este valor como el
coeficiente del término x a la cero así
que el coeficiente de la constante es la
constante 2.544
respecto al coeficiente de la cafeína
acabamos de decir que x es la cantidad
de cafeína que se consume por lo que
este es el coeficiente 0.160 y 4 y así
de sencillo tenemos la ecuación para
nuestra recta de regresión y es por eso
que son útiles estas salidas de
computadora lo escribimos 10 sombrero es
igual a cero punto 164 por x + 2.544
esta es nuestra recta de regresión y de
que se trata de esta otra información
que nos dan no les voy a dar una
respuesta muy satisfactoria ya que todo
esto se usa para estadística inferencial
para pensar en cosas como cuál es la
probabilidad de que tengamos algo que
coincida perfectamente con esto esto de
aquí es la r al cuadrado y si queremos
encontrar la r a partir de esto
calculamos la raíz cuadrada de esto 0.60
1.032 dependiendo de qué tanta precisión
tengan pero como sabemos cierre es la
raíz cuadrada positiva o la raíz
cuadrada negativa r puede tomar valores
de 1 negativo hasta 1 positivo y la
respuesta es observar la pendiente de la
recta si tenemos una pendiente positiva
entonces tendremos una r positiva si
tenemos una pendiente negativa entonces
tendremos una r negativa esto de aquí es
la raíz cuadrada ajustada pero no nos
preocuparemos mucho por esto cuando se
trata de datos variados como la cafeína
y las horas de estudio en este caso si
tuviéramos más variables para tratar de
explicar las horas de estudio
entonces nos interesaría usarla r
cuadrada ajustada pero no la usaremos en
este momento finalmente tenemos esta
variable s que es la desviación estándar
del residuo que estudiamos en vídeos
anteriores y para que no sea sutil es
una medida de que también coincide la
recta de regresión con los datos podemos
decir que es una medida del error típico
en resumen las computadoras son muy
útiles porque nos proporcionan mucha
información lo importante es saber cómo
elegir las cosas que vamos a necesitar
ya qué
y sabemos lo que necesitamos
encontraremos esto muy rápidamente y con
esto terminamos